hallo mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren vor zwei wochen habe ich ein
video auf einem kanal hochgeladen in dem
wir uns zusammen youtube videos
angeschaut haben die null
aufrufe haben ja das war komisch und
deswegen kommt jetzt 2
[Musik]
also das hier ist das erste video mit 0
aufrufen es trägt den namen ja keiner
aussprechen
hier sehen wir auf jeden fall einen zug
der ich weiß ja bei gleich irgendwo
vielleicht an entgegenfährt aber nein er
fährt einfach erfährt meisterwerk
dennoch film
[Musik]
der sieht ja nicht so schön aus aber gut
die website zeigt uns ja unendlich viele
videos mit 0 aufruf man von daher würde
ich sagen schauen uns direkt das nächste
video an
[Musik]
sind das einfach
videos wie leute mit ihren hof warum
bist du so ein haus zu verkaufen
ganz ehrlich die verkäufe scheinen ja
nicht so gut zu laufen wenn die videos
keine aufrufe haben nächstes video ist
das hier das ist er hat sich einen neuen
akku vor gekauft
[Musik]
a von oliver kumulation ach so aus dem
februar 2009 10 risiko das mit skripten
aha
das warum halten so was nun aufrufe luca
vollidiot singular von vollidioten
referenz luca
also da kann ich echt nicht genug von
kriegen von den häusern angeboten also
ein superschönes wohnzimmer auch hier
ich verstehe auch nicht was wir jetzt
gerade sagen wer frisst sein essen und
der das also das ist wirklich freude die
konnten wir sehen wir noch nicht so
richtig was abgeht
der typ gelegt sein handy dorthin und ja
kein ding liga das ist
[Musik]
was soll die scheiße hier haben wir ein
video von einer person die
augenscheinlich in dem lamborghini setzt
nehmen müssen ist an der skyline gt-r
die falls ein rennen gegeneinander damit
nicht so also sind die straße abgesperrt
wäre und ich glaube deren design gewinnt
also wirklich glückwunsch an der stelle
an den nissan fahrer
falls ihr euch frage ob der ton schrott
ist nee der ist einfach das war's
[Musik]
ich glaube dass hier jemand seine
vorlesung mit gefällt hat auch jetzt
raus gegangen jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt
jagen gegangen hammer alter das video
das einen richtigen spannungs effekt
drin der wahl zum ersten mal wieder so
richtig vernünftiges qualitativ
hochwertiges video eben da ist ein
kleines kind da nicht verrutschen eine
vertikale rede macht das nicht also ich
hab keine ahnung ob die wir jetzt
wirklich runter rutschen wird
die wird auch schon ein bisschen
angezogen da oben und jetzt jetzt wird
sie gehalten und sie rutscht alter ich
hätte mich das nicht getraut repariert
glaube ich einen vorhang
[Musik]
java ist das super liga weiter so warum
mir der turbo so hoch an der stelle wo
ich das heute wieder ist alex band meine
lieben freunde wenn ihr euch meine
reaktion mal wieder auf die website
youtube also auf die website die einem
zufällig irgendwelche youtube-videos die
keine aufrufe haben an zeit gefallen hat
dann das gerne einen daumen hoch unter
dem video hier da und abonniert main
kanal fall zogaj der user
[Musik]